bolsonaro ha sacudido la base de su
gobierno y ha realizado de una vez seis
cambios en el gabinete que han sido
anunciados a través de una serie de
tuits tres ministros han dejado el
gobierno incluido el ministro de
exteriores- ernesto araújo y el ministro
de defensa fernando acevedo de silva
araujo se alineó con la anterior
administración estadounidense y se
pronunció en contra de china el
principal socio comercial de brasil esto
le granjeó las críticas del presidente
que consideró que su postura en pidió un
acceso más rápido a las vacunas contra
el coronavirus por otro lado la salida
de acevedo del ministerio de defensa fue
una sorpresa ha sido reemplazado por el
actual jefe de gabinete de bolsonaro
walter souza braga neto uno de los
muchos ex generales del ejército en la
cúspide del gobierno este año los
índices de aprobación de bolsonaro han
descendido la pandemia ha matado a más
de 300.000 personas en el país que ahora
se encuentra en su peor momento con más
de 3000 muertes diarias
bolsonaro ha mostrado dudas sobre las
vacunas y se ha opuesto a los
confinamientos respecto
obviamente necesitamos respetar a los
ancianos los enfermos y aquellos con
problemas médicos
pero qué pasa a la compra sin si paramos
todo si nos paramos a mediados de marzo
bolsonaro ya había realizado un cambio
de gobierno
reemplazando al ministro de salud
eduardo para suelo el cuarto en la
cartera de este gobierno quien había
sido ampliamente criticado por la
lentitud en el programa de vacunación